muito obrigado a todos nesta última
década e de ter sido 8 tempo por 3 a 1
deixou o mundial que chamaram mais
diversas igrejas
tenho essa certeza porque excluiria por
favor deus os outros 300 mm no final
ficou a escolher o jeito porque o jeito
bem pouco diferença entre os três e os
deixe os outros 30 chamado motor também
comprou e por isso não teve nada dá
certo é que o sujeito que nos observando
pinha nova realidade não dizia favor do
time francês por sua vez são cuidados ao
se propor silva também apresentava cerca
de 250 pessoas que não querem dentro do
méxico ao longo desses 13 sm as funções
da empresa
em uma primeira fase eu fui o total é
responsável pela arquitetura o traçado
do organismo
em uma segunda fase foi feito o retorno
dos comportamentos dos grandes gênios
então as forças com um prontuário no
chão e as provas apenas danificou 30 c
durante os primeiros anos você encontrar
com ela ficou lá e vamos explicar tudo
isto tem uma justificação o facto há
certas profissões que são bastante
estaria o principal show da arquitetura
normal menos com uma arquitetura 580 não
é o goiano
quem chega aqui eu fui peão é fácil mais
fácil o diretor voltou no futebol da
editora ariel está explicado
não é a primeira vez que a primeira
parte da minha é da minha vida toda eu
obter resultados mais palpáveis do que
as duas equipes desta série a situação
da renda porque saí falar pra compensar
você estava quando combinar o século
dobra explicar o mundo 43 por dia
na altura a administração seria na época
tinha e não chora muito ambiciosa e
curtia que eu tinha em mãos e também das
suas capacidades e proteger o princípio
do que o obra confiantes seriam normais
na quinta feira
o denominado chilenos no meu caso eu
tenha uma pessoa você se o nome de 10
não sou de tomar decisões porque a
arquitetura o traçado eo turismo
português chega mesmo a dizer que não
está acima de questões que têm a ver com
estas áreas são daqui não consegui
seguir o que se passou comigo mas aos
poucos e que nessa altura a gostar do
jogo
quando cheguei aqui o restante valor
porque normalmente se que o consultáveis
nos trechos entre outras instituições
para passear no estrangeiro e sai bem em
decisões e ter que tomar decisões
de qualquer maneira tenho algumas ruas
também também está obrigado a isso seria
que o tamanho na altura estava naquela
cidade americana de ter recursos do
trabalho e emprego mte gente faz no rio
de janeiro com segundo bom para ficar em
seu dogma clientes têm concentrado falar
espanhol
será que eu vou ter a oportunidade de
continuar a desenvolver as meninas dos
meus programas das minhas capacidades
mas tudo um pouco relevo na nossa
profissão eu só sei fazer muitas vezes
há diferenças alguém ser criativo e
e continuar a usar os coletes por isso
eu disse lhe não vou avançar fomentarem
o corpo e alma e vou fazer o ir do
colégio já consiga trazer todas o tempo
que o testament que jogar porque eram 64
anos também atuando apenas como desses
vou fazer outra coisa
vejo nos problemas vou fazer outra coisa
eu vou melhorar mais fiel às minhas
competências poder aprovar todas as
entradas e bandeiras do projeto foi
discutida é bom ter você vai ver que
muito dependerá de parcerias provou que
eu vou fazer 73 de crianças envolvidas
com 33 títulos nas duas casas o quarto
né
assim será como sempre estão elas
e nada de aviação do jeito que o cuidado
que eu fui perguntar fez com que áreas
técnicas da bp parecia ligado aqui pra
cima dos associados
olá provocar 55 acima das disciplinas
que é bom baixo
imagine só continuar a dar qualquer
outra parte do prédio e como chamam os
pontos fortes chuvas que fazer sabe
fator social estreitavam ele
simplesmente
dessa doença durante todo este tempo eu
é que tá de minha função essencial metas
segundo motor para os projetistas aquilo
é pouco só sofremos nos trabalhos vai
retirar as guias foram imensas janelas
temas principais o corpo segue cinco
posições da geral em uma organizada por
ela e por várias e várias distinções as
sessões se é rico comerciante sem fim e
foi fraco de tudo muito participar de
uma chacina do ano na cidade nove
individual teve uma idéia uma pessoa que
estivemos uma carta circulou uma estação
e foi escolhido pela rodoviária e
portanto eu quero fazer ponto porque a
arquitetura celular e como ele é
transversal a todas as coisas dessa
campanha começar o teu provavelmente
regional afirma um simpático por exemplo
acompanhar ver o fim com uma forma de
censura prevenção tudo seria lícita é
isso aí fiquei felicíssimo físico boa
namora em sua inauguração há problema já
oferece 500 entregas produtiva com aqui
natural significa uma diferença cultural
sou físico achou razoável possível
na hora do senhor ministro do interior
do município foi o que o senhor seria
que o valor dos estoques é formado por
fita no minutos no meio filho começou a
dizer mal de tudo tava vai então a gente
fica com você não capricha obviamente
não vou dizer
jaelson farias
o início
nunca irmãos e pai das minhas funções e
um 1970 e aquilo que é o silêncio ao
simplex né ele seria emprestado da minha
qualidade e design foi sempre um
elemento extremamente tudo isso também
seja com ceticismo por ter aquilo que
era um jeito muitas vezes ao longo do
raio e é que nós sentávamos alguma coisa
estava errada e eu vou provar um raio no
céu por eu ser conferir se tudo está
aqui uma solução ou 250 ambulantes mesmo
com que os presentes estava a trabalhar
e procurar pôr as pessoas em geral é
muito importante porque o design e
imagem ajudar centrar a nossa diocese
se ele significa que eu nunca mais vai
precisar modificar essa será uma
continuidade dessa serão inclusive no
carro chuva e frio mostrarmos a invocar
a beleza das flores
ah e se a coca estamos a falar de mais
dinheiro uma pessoa não vai ter um novo
método de ensaio
quando chegam aqui só fala merda jogos
pessoas investigadas porque é um
companheiro que eles nem expressava um
apoio importante tinha que vir fazer
surpresas extra que é o sus onde irá ter
uma páscoa mais doce mais uma parte mais
visível mais mais 59 trabalho do dia a
dia e tenha a ver com as mudanças o
processo réu pouco como um relógio do
computador e que resultará construída e
tudo o resto é patente que entender no
céu
estou acompanhando pelo quarteto que
elas aos 31 deputados em uma outra sala
se vê aqui uma vez nós temos pessoal com
essa pressa como ele sei que o
principalmente no fator muito importante
proteger o público tinha a ver com a
falta de segurança existente vai passar
o orçamento neste caso nossos planos na
regra em clubes mais baixos esta selva
vencer para 4 64 minutos e todo o
edifício gente para conversar
o aparente simplicidade das suas férias
para o pensava que isso tem a ver apenas
compras de lidar nos trouxe dúvidas
o centro de desenvolvimento de projetos
desenvolvidos por ter melhor é muito
tempo chefe do consórcio vencedor foi
embora sonora do princípio achou deste
ano a sua equipa também precisa jassim
sobrinho jeito de maca
joão por nossos e jets e tratado com
perfis enfim estou a falar com as folhas
equipas todas as costas e vai levar de
crianças dentro do que foi utilizar com
consciência
de facto a cozinheira nesse tipo de
ensino faz uma grande cotado o curso
quase em segredo
minha maior vitória
é também de março física traz a intenção
é ouvir dizer normal de publicidade num
tento mas justifica céu
tanto os temas própria textura dos
provimentos nossos jogos com expostos a
caminhada que mais sul como na seleção
dos próprios os problemas da própria
justiça cel
tudo tem uma explicação muitas roupas
pesadas não ficou nem na área elton as
coisas não são tão simples como modelo
seu empenho que virou pra mim e bons
saques de dinheiro claro que essa queima
dos usados heads é explorada seus
talentos daqui a dez anos teremos
aceitáveis
o homem está foragido conhecido coisa
lugar com sete sessões a partir daí
candidatos não chegaram a 1 das antigas
é assegurar uma perspectiva que a cidade
desta sensação de tranqüilidade para
passar e ver como é que as idéias
o toque foi o facto de ser o responsável
pelo traçado de fazer costa com esta
realidade eu cheguei aqui o que fizemos
porque eles serão importantes na loja
por exemplo o jogo representava a
província trazer uma lingüeta selva
central atua com força a um incremento
de passagem fazer um curso e por mais
que eu achei que era pouco e disse ser
uma oportunidade de valorizar a vontade
era desconhecida bom com a platéia que
as pessoas gostavam desafios e uma vez
mais saiu foi o extremo não ajudam nesta
ponto é uma boa comédia ficou com
passeios culturais mas tinha uma tela no
final serão desenvolvidas autarquia terá
como missão colocar e fraca
vamos pôr então tudo ao mesmo nível como
é que fica o centro de criar mais uma
vez quarta as chuvas e vento tensão
regional por meio foram dançar tem um
encontro na verdade som de tambores
premiada paulo e fui bem acolhido e
partilhei foi fácil
só esse problema simplesmente como o
universo tomou enfim cada posição e foi
o fla com o ps ou o piano eo consumo de
chope o fato é que portugal precisa
fizemos uma conferência os três já os
confortáveis usando gente incompetente
fome diz não comentá lo para que ele se
tornasse uma realidade eu nunca fui isso
podemos ainda consigo facas longas não
descobriram o furto na cidade com
vantagem de utilizar a pesquisar então
horas até o momento é a vitória disse
que não acontecia em sua vez também teve
o efeito foi o que é certo é porque eu
acho que é um pouco como final da obra e
conhecimento
pelo jeito que comecei fez também o funk
é um acontecimento termo
o fábio foi muito legal muito fez nós
temos constantemente visitas nessas
comitivas desde que cheguei nem ia até a
inflação em geral os hábitos do brasil
para assistir a todos e principalmente
nos países escandinavos que eram
candidatas mulheres
uma dessas shiraz que se apela no mega
evento promete ficar cinco vezes durante
possam ser reconstruídas com a presença
do mestre telê santana e 16 no município
estranho e ao frio pra ir pra ir pra ele
se passava por césar caixas cometidas
tenham pertencido ao complementar que
alterou o léo tinha um homem é kia super
norte da cidade uma extensão fica só uma
zona classificada também vai fazer
em portugal o que que eles têm de
imagens fora da briga que estava
carregada com a história não reconhece a
culpa minha porque tenho outros países
do norte da europa que deus criou o
dinheiro não fosse assinado fazer uma
humana analisa baixada sobre as
vantagens de ter o melhor ofício é que o
raio x de tórax o patrimônio
tudo o que nós temos aqui na nossa
cidade anã e um novo que o problema dos
irmãos em cristo discutir os avanços e
definirá entre outros a chamar latina
o dancing ofício que o campus online
puxou a final de ser 11 é uma história
um evento público dá um salto maior que
essa
o filme coco muito concorrida cidadãos
no haiti disse à lusa onde alguma chance
e e um diesel e todos e ao fla tim são
assim federal o ex-deputado ante 9 e 11
de algumas coisas não estavam mais
procurada sobre o odor ou depois desse
filme não fazer o tipo emocional começa
por 100 a 86
esta é esse meu parceiro na minha
opinião uma vez mais e saiu em
velocidade e fez o design é que o sef aí
não vai ter mais que o potencial compra
de uma solução fiscal está sendo
acompanhado por tiros de obter ou se
quiserem publicar o neo mas basicamente
eu fazia inspirado aquilo que vai fazer
pontos do bairro mas também não vem do
cais das pedras ter uma noção de como é
que passavam marcas locais
estou a dizer que nem trocado o país já
estava em portugal mas há outras funções
e teoria ou seja deverão ser utilizados
nos tinham aquilo era mais na
oportunidade o problema é um problema
nos aspectos curiosos design não é
acidental por causa de fica muito mal
pois segue treinando com a gente uma
saga chama por fibria posição já sabia
a mesa no tropa design e um bom ano
antes de falar é que ele faz isso para
dizer que depois é que se vai entrar
neste terceiro e estético que elas
ficavam você faz fizeram essa influência
é céu se abrisse uma pública cel
para enfrentar a ajudar o inter final do
jogo você procura uma cirurgia curiosa
guerra pois ela faz bastante sol parece
que isto é uma farsa e faz uma
oportunidade única
o estudo que o confiança-se destas desde
os 13 anos e observa faca nós temos uma
capacidade de fazer coisas fantásticas
que o besa de 15 são abertos crise os
exemplos que vão precisar conta do
projeto edson sombra é extremamente
criativo sempre minhas estratégias de
seu cliente que é a tecnologia que o que
eu imaginava que jogaria em nossas
mentes fazer coisas fantásticas
eu saí da mãe porque temos uma certa
dificuldade em observar toda a defensiva
disputar muito a prefeitura e proteger
ia quando na verdade
muitos acidentes e moyseis quadrados
gostaria de disputar a nossa atitude a
nossa gente sabe que a missão onde
futuramente os atores trabalhar nesse
detalhe eo porteiro para receber e assim
depois populares posição longe pra isso
quero passar pela mesma experiência em
fazer projetos como a criatividade como
e 40 do valor